let's do some more of these classic aged
word problems so we're told that William
is four times as old as men 12 years ago
William was seven times as old as Ben
how old is Ben now so once again it's a
good idea to try to do this on on your
own first and then I'll work through it
so what's the unknown here well the
unknown here is how old is Ben now so
let's set a variable equal to that and
we do X or Y but since Ben starts with a
B let's use B for Ben so let's let let's
let B equal Ben's current age Ben's age
now so let's see how all of this other
information relates to Ben's current age
and then maybe we can set up some
equation and then solve for things so
I'll do it a little bit more structured
in this one you could have done many of
the problems we've been working on in
this way so let's think about Ben let's
think about then and then let's think
about William Abdul William in blue here
so let's think about William William and
then there's two points in time we're
talking about we're talking about now
today and we're going to talk about 12
years ago so let's talk about so over
here let's say today or let's call that
now this will be our now column and then
this will be our 12 years ago 12 years
ago so let's see what we can fill in
here so what is Ben's age now well we
just define that is the variable B
that's the UH know that's what we have
to figure out so let's just stick that
there so that's going to be that's just
going to be B well what's Ben's age 12
years ago and so when we would maybe
want to express it in terms of B well if
he's B now 12 years ago he was just B
minus 12 fair enough now what is
Williams age today well this first
sentence gave us the information William
is four times as old as Ben and we can
assume that they're talking about today
is is four times as old as bad so if Ben
is be William is going to be for B for B
and so how old was William 12 years ago
well if he's for B right now 12 years
ago he'll just be 12 less than that
so he's for B now 12 years ago it was
for B minus 12 so that's kind of
interesting
but we haven't quite yet made use of the
second statement 12 years ago William so
this is William 12 years ago 12 years
ago William was seven times as old as
man so 12 years ago this number is going
to be 7 times this number or another way
to think about it take this number and
multiply it by 7 7 and you're going to
get this number 12 years ago then was
Ben's age is 1/7 of Williams age or
Williams age is seven times Ben's age so
let's see if we can set that up as an
equation so we can have we can have 7
times this let me write this down 7
times
Ben's age 1012 years ago
7 times 10 Ben's age 12 years ago B
minus 12 is going to be equal to
Williams age is going to be equal to
Williams age and it seems like we've
done the hard part we've set up the
equation now we just use a little bit of
our algebraic tools to solve for B so
let's do that so the first thing we
might want to do we could distribute the
7 so 7 times B 7 times essentially
negative 12 or so we have 7 B minus 7
times 12 let's see 7 it's 84 84 is going
to be equal to 4 B minus 12 is going to
be equal to 4 B minus 12 this is this
whole expression is already seven times
Ben's age 12 years ago now what can we
do to solve this well we can subtract 4
B from both sides so let's do that for B
I can do two steps at the same time well
actually let's just let's just
keep it simple so I'm going to subtract
4 B from both sides that goes away on
the right hand side I have a negative 12
on the left-hand side I'm left with 7 B
minus 4 B is 3 B and then I still have a
minus 84 well I want to get rid of this
negative 84 this minus 84 on the left
hand side so let's add 84 to both sides
let's add 84 to both sides on the left
hand side I'm just left with 3 B and on
the right hand side I have negative 12
plus 84 or 84 minus 12 which is 7d 272
now if I want to solve for B I just have
to divide both sides of that equation by
3 and so I am left with B is equal to a
now we have our drumroll 72 divided by 3
and you might be able to do that in your
head it would be 24 I believe and you
could work it out on paper if you have
trouble let's just do it real quick
72 3 goes into 7 2 times then you get a
you get a 2 times 3 is 6 subtract you
get bring down the 2 3 goes into 12 4
times so B is equal to 24 going back to
our question what is Ben's age now it is
24 and let's verify that this is
actually the case so they're telling us
that William is four times as old as bed
so what is Williams current age well 4
times 24 is 96
so William is a is a CD 8 we should call
him mr. William so let's see is 96 years
old maybe he's Ben's grandfather or
great-grandfather and they say 12 years
ago William well 12 years ago William
was 84 years old so he was 84 years old
they say that 7 times as old as Ben well
12 years ago Ben if he's 24 now Ben was
Ben was 12 and indeed 84 is 7 times 12
so it all worked out